if we dig into the psychological
preparation is there something to your
mental preparation that you do that
makes you successful like what are the
lessons over all these years that you
learned what works what doesn't do you
drink a bunch of whiskey the night
before is there is
there some small hacks or major ones
about how you approach the game it's
really hard sort of in a way because I
feel like I'm two different people I was
one person up until the pandemic as a
professional chess player solely where I
earned all my income everything was
derived from that and from the pandemic
on I'm sort of a different person
because that is not where where I'm
making my income from and so the whole
psychological profile that I had before
is completely different from now uh
there's this this this joke about the I
literally don't care phrase that I've
used and in a sense what that means is
not that I don't care obviously I'm
competitive I want to do well but if I
lose the game or I don't do well in a
tournament it's not the end of the world
in the same kind of way that I felt it
was before because that pressure of
needing to always perform was very very
high
um and so I think before before the
pandemic what I would try to do more
than anything is just not think about
the previous game for the most part like
say I had a bad game I'd go out for a
walk that evening just clear my mind
these sorts of things now they aren't
really hacks per se but it's trying
essentially to have short-term memory
loss
[Laughter]
so I literally don't care it's not just
the meme it's a it's a philosophy in a
sense it's a way of being I mean it's
it's basically that yes like I do want
to perform well I'm going to give it my
all but it's not like it if I lose a
game it's not the end of the world that
should be the title of your auto
autobiography and it should be uh
like uh I I know you're probably
Immortal but if you do happen to die
this should also be on YouTube so uh
Charles Bukowski has uh don't try on his
Tombstone yes which which I think
emphasizes a similar concept but
slightly different more in the artistic
domain which is uh well a lot of people
have different interpretations of that
statement but I think it means
don't take
things too seriously yeah I I mean I I
agree with that completely I think that
um if you if you look at my career prior
to the pandemic I put huge amounts of
pressure on myself because
I really want to be as good as I could
be but but it was the way I was earning
and living in one thing that's very
difficult about Chess is that only the
top 20 maybe 30 players in the world
make a living from the game now you make
a very good living
um no way am I diminishing chess but the
problem with it is it's not secure at
all so if you don't get invitations to
the absolute top tournaments which have
prize funds from anywhere from maybe a
hundred thousand up to potentially half
a million dollars if you don't get those
invitations it's very very hard to earn
a living you can go from earning maybe
two hundred thousand three hundred
thousand dollars a year to earning like
fifty thousand so it's very very
unstable and I think
um for myself I really put a lot of
pressure on myself and in a way that it
affected me and not not in a good way